[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est plaisant parce que on a pas
beaucoup de moments de loisirs on a pas
beaucoup de moments de pour se détacher
de cette responsabilité de la pression
de réseautage pouvez-vous
mon père il était artiste et souvent il
y avait des musiciens à la maison quand
j'étais petit et ça c'est quelque chose
qui revient à l'esprit et qui qui donne
cette image d'une famille qui est
ensemble qui partage des choses
imperturbable parfois le regard noir
mais toujours souriant
13 ans que Marcelo francovia qui est
loin du Brésil entraîneur en Europe et
depuis 3 ans ça grenouille à Tours
c'est un plaisir d'être en France pour
moi très sincèrement je j'adore la
couture française j'adore la langue
française
et il volait français c'était quelque
chose de très important pour moi
je savais que en arrivant à Tours
j'allais avoir cette possibilité de
disputer des titres de montrer vraiment
la qualité de mon travail avec une
structure capable de vraiment bien faire
et c'est le cas
ce jour-là veille de la finale retour du
championnat face à Chaumont la tension
est à son apogée Marcelo francovia
canalise une nouvelle fois les grandes
failles du match aller ponctué par une
défaite sèche 3 zéro
là il a quitté deux options voilà et là
le bloc va lire il va bien lire voilà
c'est un mec de maître disent et qui
saute si vous regardez bien
c'est vachement agressif
le lendemain 3000 supporters sont là
pour soutenir le TVB face à son ultime
défi mais la responsabilité a tortella
elle est très grande elle est très
grande parce que il a un passé derrière
moi
j'ai toujours dit que la performance
elle est liée le contrôle de la
technique de la tactique il faut savoir
lire le jeu il faut avoir une bonne
condition physique mais il faut avoir un
mental d'acier
au bout de l'adversité le tour
volley-ball remporte finalement son
neuvième titre de champion de France
mais pour Marcelo victoire ou défaite
l'essentiel de la vie reste le partage
la relation à l'autre pour moi peut-être
que la vie est ça c'est se mettre
disponible pour essayer de construire
c'est un pour romantique c'est un peu
c'est un peu fou aussi mais
les biens communs quoi la bienveillance
de choses qui qui qui j'ai appris avec
mes parents qui j'essaye de partager
avec mon épouse avec avec mes enfants
avec des gens qui passent dans ma vie
[Musique]
demain nous serons avec le monument du
volet français du tout volley-ball
Pascal Foucart